DAN FELD: Hi.
Welcome to Founders World
2015 here in Pier 27
in San Francisco.
And here with me today--
CONAN REIS: Is Conan Reis.
DAN FELD: What's up?
[LAUGHTER]
CONAN REIS: Well, uh, we
do a video game programming
language, and when
you tell people
you're bringing a new
language into the world,
the first response is
generally, you're nuts.
DAN FELD: You're nuts.
Yeah, absolutely.
CONAN REIS: And so
we're in the business
of doing the things where
they say, you can't do that.
And we say, yes, we can.
So it's a very mad
scientist ethos,
so we call ourselves
mad computer scientists.
DAN FELD: It is.
And I think that worked very
well looking at the expo floor
here and people that
have surrounded you.
CONAN REIS: Yeah.
DAN FELD: I think
it works great.
Also, I think it's two
days after the "Back
to the Future"--
CONAN REIS: Yes.
Yes.
DAN FELD: --big day so--
CONAN REIS: We definitely
Tweeted about that.
DAN FELD: Well done.
CONAN REIS: Fans of Doc Brown.
DAN FELD: Aren't we all?
CONAN REIS: Yes.
DAN FELD: So tell us a little
bit about this language
and what can we do with it?
CONAN REIS: Well, it's only
taken 20 years to make,
so it's the next
overnight success story.
DAN FELD: Sounds like a
great entrepreneurship cycle.
CONAN REIS: Yeah.
So in the video
game industry, lots
of the different
components that you
use to make video games,
physics, animation, graphics,
all those different
systems, they've
kind of become commoditized.
You can get amazing things
for free, for, you know,
hundreds of
thousands of dollars,
but the game play part
of games, generally,
each company will make those
sorts of things from scratch.
And then when they're
done, their amazing game
and their amazing tech,
they throw it away.
And every single game after
iteration after iteration,
they have to build it
from scratch every time.
And when I started in the
industry about 22 years ago,
I thought that was crazy.
And it made sense that we
would make that aspect of game
development easier.
And a lot of it had
to do with things
like concurrency,
all sorts of things
happening at the same time.
Interactivity.
DAN FELD: But perhaps
decode it for us.
I know I'm not an
expert in this,
but I know that there
are engines like Unity
and others that that's
supposed to give you
some platform for
repetition, right?
CONAN REIS: Sure.
But all of the tools
that have generally
been used in the
industry still are
languages that you can add
in some of those things
after the fact, but it's
not native to the language.
So to make interactive concepts
a native part of the language,
it dramatically
changes the workflow
in terms of how
people do things.
Usually to do a game that does
something that takes time,
you have to break up time into
tiny little bits and pieces
every frame.
And to think about
that as us mere humans,
it's not a natural process.
That's not how we think.
So this language
enables you to be
able to describe things
in a more natural way.
These five things or thousand
things happen at the same time,
and when, you know, the
first of them completes,
do this other thing.
And cue the music and
the bad guys come in.
And, you know, all of those
simultaneous actions that
are happening, most of
the computer languages,
those are sort of add on
things from the operating
system or just to describe it
takes ages of complex code.
DAN FELD: It is.
CONAN REIS: But with
SkookumScript, you
can describe the
same sorts of things
in just a couple of lines.
So the understanding of
being able to-- like,
the main problem in software
engineering is we're
stuck with the
brains than we have.
DAN FELD: Yes.
CONAN REIS: And we have to fit
only what we can, you know,
hold in our brains.
So if you can do the
most interesting things
with a very short
amount of code,
then you can fit a
lot more in your head.
DAN FELD: And also, I
assume that you have--
you can put less energy
into the engineering--
CONAN REIS: Yes.
DAN FELD: --and more energy into
the content and the innovation
and the difference
that you want to bring.
CONAN REIS: Precisely.
DAN FELD: And would
that be something
that is ready to roll?
What would be the call
for action for anyone
that wants to take a shot at it?
CONAN REIS: Well, it's been
evolving in the games industry
as sort of an in-house
tool for many years,
but we've thought
now is the time
to get it out across the
entire game industry.
So we're just starting
to release it.
We've been doing it sort
of in a closed beta.
It's hooked up as a free
plug-in with the Unreal Engine,
and that is supposed to be on
their marketplace as a code
plug-in in a couple weeks to a
month or something like that.
So everyone will be
able to get it for free
and start using it
and playing with it.
And everything it does
is also in real time.
So unlike a lot of languages,
you can type in some code
and see immediately how
it's changing things.
So if some character's
acting in some weird way,
instead of shutting it
down, making your change,
recompiling-- and some
of the big projects,
it's half an hour to
rebuild-- in SkookumScript,
you can make your change live
while the game is running
and see the little guys that
you have running around acting
and behaving--
DAN FELD: Live change.
CONAN REIS: --instantly.
DAN FELD: Where do
you find this product?
What do people--
CONAN REIS: skookumscript.com.
DAN FELD: Oh, I see.
CONAN REIS: And soon on the
Unreal marketplace as a plug-in
into their development system.
And it will work
on all platforms.
DAN FELD: Excellent.
That's great, and good luck.
We are looking forward to that.
Perhaps a few words
about your background and
how did you-- about your
professional background?
CONAN REIS: Oh, so I've been
in the video game industry
for many years.
I studied cognitive
science and AI,
and so the big part of what
I've been wanting to do
is make it easier to have
the computer take on as much
of the effort it can to help
us develop things, right?
I mean, languages
and stuff that we've
worked with used to
have to work on systems
that were really underpowered.
But these days, everybody has
a supercomputer on their phone
in their pocket, so there's no
reason that the computers can't
do more for us.
So I've always thought about
intelligent agents and AI.
And so I'm trying to bring
that sort of intelligence
into languages and compiling
and what you describe,
your crazy ideas
of the stories you
want to tell, to put into this.
My background is I started
at Electronic Arts in Canada,
had my own company, made
the first sort of language,
got a big government grant
to do it, went to Lucas Arts
here in San Rafael and worked
on some languages there.
I actually made a language
called Chewy script,
after Chewbacca, because he's
the engineer in the Star Wars
universe.
So if you got an
error, it would go--
[CHEWBACCA NOISE]
And then went back and started
working on SkookumScript,
and that was in 2004 in Canada.
DAN FELD: Wow.
CONAN REIS: And so it's-- then
used it internally in United
Front Games in their
"Sleeping Dogs" game.
That was a big open world game.
And now they are using it to
build "Triad Wars," which is
a massively multiplayer game.
And now we want to get
it so that everyone
in the entire game development
industry can use it.
And even outside of games, too.
Robotics, aerospace
industries, anything
that does real time automation
would benefit from this.
Any high-level sort of
stage direction-type stuff.
DAN FELD: Outstanding.
And perhaps I will ask you
the same identical questions
we ask everyone.
What's your favorite or
most used Google product?
CONAN REIS: Well, like
many, it's probably,
you know, just Search.
But, I mean, we use
Google Analytics.
It's hooked into our product
to track and figure out
how things are being used.
And very soon, hopefully,
lots of Android
use, because with
games there's going
to be lots of people writing
SkookumScript Android games.
DAN FELD: Looking forward to it.
Thank you very much, Conan.
CONAN REIS: Thank you.
DAN FELD: Thank you.
And than you very
much for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]